there are certain
rules when it comes to movies it's
always the girl who survives a killer
it has to rain during every funeral
and yes the third film in a trilogy
almost always sucks
and it's not just the terrible ones some
of the most
critically acclaimed trilogies also
suffer from the three equal curse
and it got us wondering what's really
happening here
the first thing we needed to find out
was just how common bad threquals really
are and surprisingly the hardest part
was deciding
what exactly constitutes a film trilogy
in our case it's a set of three films
that share
a continuous story character or theme
this means that independent trilogies
like iron man
and annabelle within an existing
franchise count
but trilogies that are continued years
later like born or
pirates of the caribbean don't
we then took 70 of the highest
domestically grossing trilogies in the
us
and calculated each film's average
rotten tomato score
based on both critic and audience
ratings to get a more accurate depiction
the list includes the obvious big
hitters like the godfather
and the karate kid as well as a few
unexpected gems like ice cube's barber
shop trilogy
ricky what what hey you think you doing
over there hey look i'm just trying to
get them clean like them gillette
commercial
average out all the scores for first
second and third film
put them on a chart and you get
something like this
the first film was the obvious winner
with an average score of 71
followed by the sequel at 58 and three
queens at 52.
count them all up and 64 of trilogies
had their three quail as their worst
film so why are threequels
almost always the worst ones there are
two factors that come into play here
formula and necessity the reason why
film trilogies have been around for so
long is that they're a really great
structure to tell a long story
with each film serving as a beginning a
middle and an
end this also means that each film
should serve a very specific
purpose no matter the genre the first
film always serves as an origin story
that introduces us to our heroes and the
world they live in
that's why successful first movies
usually fit into one of two categories
one adapted materials from an existing
body of work
like the silence of the lambs or the
star trek reboot
that accurately capture the essence of
the original source material
or two fresh original ips
like the matrix and star wars that are
quite unlike anything the audience has
seen
the sequels always tend to enjoy more
freedom
since their characters and worlds are
already established for them
for this reason the second film is all
about heroes facing the greatest
challenge they've faced yet whether it
be iconic villains or a battle that just
seems impossible to win
this is where the problem with three
goals comes in there isn't really a
formula for a successful
threequel at least not yet and while
sequels can usually stand on their own
and focus on telling a good story
morning partner prequels have a lot more
to accomplish
they not only have to tell a great story
that tops the films before it but they
also need to
tie every loose end and somehow bring a
satisfying conclusion to the saga
in almost exactly the same length as the
other films
studios often try to solve this problem
with a bigger budget to visually raise
the stakes
but it often just comes off as
repetitive some prequels actually repeat
previous successes as a strategy like
how return of the jedi
was really a rehash of a new hope but
with a bigger death star
and spider-man 3 which crams so many
villains into one film
just replicates the same plot beats as
its previous film
which brings us to an even bigger
problem necessity
trilogies suffer the most when they're
just not needed at all
skim through 33 of the worst rated
trilogies
and you could argue that about 85 of
those films aren't needed after the
first film
after the hangover part 2 destroyed
everything the first film did right
by replicating it there were no loose
ends that needed to be tied up
nor any separate conclusions to be made
but two years later the hangover part 3
still arrived in theaters with an even
more abysmal rating
so despite all of this why does
hollywood keep making
terrible sequels the answer seems
obvious money right
well the box office shows that each
movie in a trilogy
generally makes less money than the one
that came before
but their differences aren't big enough
to not warrant a threequel
on average that third movie still makes
four times more than its budget
and as long as we continue to watch them
the problem will likely
never be resolved the curse of three
quel's
is an issue that perhaps best
illustrates the problems with how
hollywood approaches a film
a good film can only be achieved with a
good story
and one studios forget that eternal fact
what they're releasing at the end
isn't a film but a product without a
[Music]
soul